now first from our eight news now i-team
we are learning more about the abuse of
a four-year-old boy found dead in a
freezer reportedly enduring months of
abuse before his death david charns here
now with new photos and testimony
revealing some startling details in this
case
just real startling details denise mason
dominguez's mother told the grand jury
her son's accused killer her boyfriend
told her to take him out of pre-k for
fear somebody would see his injuries as
we've told you six months later police
found that little boy's body in a
freezer in the home they all shared his
mother locked upstairs
photos show the inside of the freezer
where police say they found the body of
four-year-old mason dominguez the
evidence shown to a grand jury includes
frozen items covering a false cardboard
bottom underneath detectives say they
found mason's body they believed it had
been there for months new court
documents the eight news now i-team
obtained monday paint a clearer picture
of what was happening inside this
northeast valley home mason's mother
telling the grand jury her boyfriend 35
year old brandon tozlund had beaten her
son with a spatula and in september she
took him out of his pre-k program quote
he forced me to withdraw him from school
she tells the grand jury he told me that
the school would think that he might be
being abused because he had bruises
every once in a while from falling and
that they were going to think something
more mason's mother saying she never
knew her son was in the freezer seen
here covered with a tire after learning
mason was dead mason's mother says
toasland kept her away from her
seven-year-old daughter and tozlin's two
children from a previous relationship
quote he kept me upstairs in the master
bedroom and he would barricade the door
with like a huge tv stand she said he
would tell me that i was going to die if
i tried doing something stupid other
photos show the handcuffs police say
they found in tozlin's car his arrest
coming after mason's seven-year-old
sister handed her teacher these posted
notes asking for police to come to the
house
we have much more about this story on
eightnewsnow.com tozlin also allegedly
held mason's mother's phone and was in
control of her social media prosecutors
say they are considering the death
penalty in this case he is charged with
murder and kidnapping i'm david sharon
is live local now